Wir sind am 21. August um etwa 6:45 Uhr,
also normalerweise in der Zeit wo man beginnt sich an den Dienst zu erinnern, alarmiert worden.
Keine zusätzlichen Maßnahmen waren erforderlich.
Der Marsch in die Kaserne, etwa 10 Minuten, Viertelstunde, ist bevorgestanden...
Ich habe während des Marsches in die Kaserne den Kompaniekommandanten der NTI Kompanie getroffen,
das war damals der Oberleutnant oder Leutnant Beirer.
Ich habe zu ihm gesagt: "Wir sind diesmal alarmiert worden ohne,
dass wir vorher irgendeine Information bekommen haben".
Er hat gesagt, dass in den Nachrichten gekommen ist,
dass die Russen in Prag einmarschiert sind und die Tschechoslowakei besetzen.
Etwa um Dreiviertel Vier haben wir den Abmarschbefehl bekommen in den Verfügungsraum zu marschieren,
die 1. und 2. Kompanie.
Wir sind im Landmarsch nach Allentsteig gefahren, das sind ca. 90km gewesen,
der M60 hat das leicht mit einem Tank bewältigt.
Wir sind mit 16 Panzer gefahren, Einer war gerade in der Werkstätte, was er hatte weiß ich nicht mehr,
und er ist uns in den Einsatzraum, in den Verfügungsraum, nachgeführt worden mit dem Tieflader
und wir sind eben in den Verfügungsraum Allentsteig in den Gerotter Wald gefahren.
Wir sind mit dem Bataillonskommando und der 2. Kompanie
Panzergrenadierbataillon 9, die damals in Weitra gewesen ist, im Raum Pötzles wo das Kommando war,
und sind in den Gerotter Wald hineingefahren und haben uns dort ungemütlich niedergelassen.
Im Verfügungsraum hatten wir kein WC und kein Wasser zum waschen.
Am nächsten oder übernächsten Tag ist ein Großraumzelt aufgebaut worden, dort haben wir geschlafen.
Wir hatten keine Möglichkeit für die Kanzlei und für Schriftverkehr usw.
Am nächsten Tag ist die Munition an die Kompanien gekommen und da haben wir den Rest der Munition aufgeladen.
Wir waren voll aufmunitioniert mit dem Panzer, die kleine Munition,
die MG Munition und die SMG Munition haben wir schon in St.Pölten gelagert gehabt,
das war überhaupt kein Problem, die Munition in den Panzer hineinzubekommen.
Am Sonntag sind jedenfalls schon unsere Frauen hinauf gekommen, da haben die Soldaten schon Ausgang bekommen,
wir sind am Samstag schon mit den Soldaten baden gefahren, baden unter Anführungszeichen.
Mit der Kompanie in den Kamm, einmal waschen, dass wir uns gewaschen haben.
Wir haben ja keine Möglichkeit gehabt im Gerotterwald, eine leichte Quelle oder irgendwas...